as a product of a lot of a female
household I think I could have used yeah
look what happens to me dude look how
soft I am yeah I have no hair on my legs
it takes me forever to grow a mustache
and he has toxic masculinity he's always
fighting all the time yeah and I you
know I could have used a lot more
masculine energy growing up I think no
like I think about that a lot actually I
think I think I could have too honestly
yeah for sure that's why we get along so
well all right turn it off dude it's
[Music]
over
welcome back to careful boys where we
are afraid of absolutely everything and
today we would like to give unsolicited
advice to a parent and that unsolicited
advice is dot dot dot oh beat the [__]
out of your kids man that's great
they're so stupid that's a good start
whoa how hard how hard would you beat
him uh I do think
that some people do not discipline their
children correctly so then everybody
else is kind of like bothered apparently
open hand slap on the butt in California
is okay yeah that's the legality of
things I think so I well I mean
discipline could come in different ways
right but there's parents that just like
let their kids go [__] wild and they
just sit there and don't do nothing do
you think it's because the parents are
undisciplined I don't know man I don't
know why like like they'll just be crazy
kids on flights and everyone's just
looking and then the parents are just
like you know kids some parents are kids
still that still need to that that still
need to be parented and then they have a
kid that's true so like it's tough
because they don't even know how to like
parent themselves yet and then now they
have something else they have to parent
which is tough I do think this is me
from having high school kids working at
my shop there's a huge difference you
can see a
major dis difference between kids that
were like taught to do chores and and
like kind of like they were they had
structure they're part of a family team
yeah versus kids that like I think their
parents did everything for them so like
one would be like a princess who doesn't
know how to do basic [__] like wipe off
a fridge correctly use like a broom like
it's almost like they never touched it
before because their parents did
everything for them and I think that
it's like you didn't you don't set up
your kids to like win in life at all cuz
you do everything for them do they is it
that or are they doing the husband cheat
code of like oh how does it work and
then your wife's like let me just do it
and then you're like like the kids are
doing that and then the mom just does it
for
them well they they succumb to that
manipulation like they or they're
falling for it or perhaps are they doing
that to you in the store oh no okay yeah
yeah cuz they just cuz they lose their
job they just we make them like learn
like I'm what was shocking to me is like
so this is how I found out is you can't
tell someone oh oh can you clean up that
corner real quick it has to be very
specific and what I realized is you
don't know in the very beginning who has
these skills and who don't like I
thought everybody knew how to mop I
thought everybody knew how to clean a
counter mhm like basic [__] right and I
was so wrong because some of these kids
that were like um their parents cleaned
their room their parents do everything
for them right this is might be their
first job and they literally don't know
how to like ring out a rag and then wipe
it down and make sure that there are no
like
streaks or like I was just like what the
[__] like and then they didn't know how
to use a mop bucket like they didn't
know how to like squeeze the mop out
ring it out I was like what
and then so without embarrassing them I
realize that in our training what we
need to do is just show them the example
and you do it first so you teach them
how to all right make sure it's like
this and you explain the thought process
it can't just be this you got to go
under here you got to make sure the dust
is clear the handles all that and I was
like damn dude you got to really like
spell it out that's pretty crazy cuz
then like how how much lower do you have
to make sure the the lowest common
denominator the anel has to cater to
that's why I think McDonald's is genius
dude what cuz they know how to train
people that might not even know how to
speak English like it's like it's
everything is like so simple that you
can get you don't you don't you know you
can't expect everyone has common sense I
think so jumping back then to Parenting
how does
this now how would you parent a kid to
to maybe Pro progress them enough so
that this this isn't happening anymore
well what we do for the kids that
probably are not parented with life
skills is like I try to not make it like
a shameful experience like you don't
know [__] [__] dumbass even though
that's what I'm
thinking I give them the tutorial with
thorough explanation and if they don't
get it right the next time then then I
can tell them got it that they're dumb
[__] yeah I think for I think
as we get better at training too I think
we have to explain things correctly and
communicate it right and then and then
not expect people to know I think that's
yeah I I do expect Tao to know though
like so like so like there's some things
where I think it's like you have to
teach it's impossible there no can be
like hey Tao [__] go on [__]
Facebook for me he's not going to know
how to do those things but I feel like
once I start laying these things out I
expect him to connect the dots cuz I'm
not not going to be able to go there and
go like this cuz I'm just handholding
right so like now with taica I'm going
to go like if I see something I don't
like that's like I think he should know
his age I I'll look at it and I'll like
hey ta I'm going to give you 3 seconds
to fix what I see wrong before you do 20
burpees and he'll just see him
like and then out of the Hun the [__]
the [__] thing he fixes 10 things
that are even like above what even what
I talked about I'm oh you're really good
at connecting the dots so he'll like did
you ever go that was 11 seconds
[Laughter]
but he'll he'll like he'll like fix like
he's like putting caps on you know I'm
like oh so you recognize there's a lot
of [__] that's [__] up here it's just
when you're in your kid mode like
everything is just like you know the
[__] cup is on the edge he's [__]
swinging the [__] scissors around
like he he when he's in kid mode he's
oblivious but then if I like smack him
back into place like you got 10 seconds
to fix this picture right now it's like
boom boom boom this is recycling bin
[__] things are color coordinate all
like he'll fix it like real quick and
I'm like oh [__] are you teaching him
that exercise is punishment I think I am
and then it also backfires because in
the middle of it he'll be like he wants
to do more he'll like can I do 20 more
burpies I'm like God damn it you're not
supposed to enjoy it you're like yeah I
actually think that's that's still
parenting even though he doesn't have to
spell it out right cuz he creates an
environment where it's like there's an
expectation to me yeah and you're not
doing it whereas like I'm telling you
dude there's so many [__] people
where their parents are not even
existent dude they don't even give a
[__] it's either they do everything for
them or there's no like level of you
have I expect this out of you you need
to get it done you're accountable for
something bro like no it's just is so
crazy and I'm like I wish that's what I
wish parents would do is like stop doing
everything for them stop like making it
too easy just like at least have a bar
and tell them to do it so then they know
that they got to do it it's on them like
and I don't even know how to uh really
teach that cuz I'm only looking at it at
a as a workplace not from like a parent
yeah like you see you see the result
yeah I feel like that should be taught
at home and then you come to the
workplace and then like you know you're
not learning it there yeah I don't know
what do you think R all you know what's
interesting is like we didn't learn how
to use computers from our parents we
just learned how to turned the thing on
and we figured everything else play
around PornHub on her own that's that's
the advice that I would give I don't
have kids or nothing but like my advice
is that like because my parents had no
idea about the internet and no idea what
I was looking at I saw some [__] up
[__] way too soon whatever that is for
kids today whether that's internet again
or that's just something
new understand what that is and put some
gates on that whatever that is cuz that
I don't know what that is for the kids
of today
I love that cuz if that's internet again
holy [__] it's probably even more Wilder
of a West than it was cuz like we saw
some [__] we saw lemon party I saw lemon
party I saw lemon part Grandpa sucking
his own dick dude no grandpa sucking
each other's dick oh
sucking hey show me lemon party bro I'll
watch that you never seen lemon party oh
watch that [__] I W even Yak once have
you ever seen meat spitters oh yeah cuz
it's men that's why you're not going to
care about lemon party you care about
blue waffle I've seen blue waffle easy
[__] to S is lemon party still around
oh they like they took it they scrubbed
it pretty good they didn't pay for their
Go Daddy that's cool don't worry about
it I guess we can't find it guess try to
Google a picture of 11 and this gu suck
it goes straight to Adriana's Insurance
now what's the other one where the guy
sucking his own dick I don't know that's
cool but yeah that's that's my that's my
own advice safe search off that's just
based on like my childhood and how I
knew I was getting away with everything
and even to this day they don't there's
no reason for them to like go back and
go you were looking at what it's like
they missed that whole [__] thing and
it was years of like unsupervised use so
like whatever today's device or thing
like figure that [__] out yeah that okay
I found it oh good all right here you go
That's a classic oh no they didn't have
the Santa hats on oh
my someone put Santa hats on that's not
that bad at all that's cake
Dude Looks Like Me and Anthony's Friday
night am I right bud have you seen a tub
girl huh the sad
tub tub girl oh tub girl is a classic
the one she's covered in [__] she's in
her own [__] all time classic is that
the one I just can't get you what about
you Anthony I'm in I like how someone's
going to click this parenting video
hoping that maybe they'll learn a thing
or two and all they learn about is the
lazy Workforce and a [__] and they
have to take their kids out of the room
they're just getting porn
suggestions what about those kid those
dudes that are like yo I've been
watching JK since I was 9 years old
oh my God where were their parents what
the [__] yeah their parents should have
been supervised on the internet for sure
dude oh I have advice I could give
myself because I'm such a [__] [__]
ass
dad sometimes I'll I'll like lay out the
rule and the consequence cuz I want him
to know structure and everything and
then like Midway through like the
consequence I like soften the blow a
little bit and I'm like
[__] and I wish I could like really
stick to it because it's like were you
going to laugh so the advice is to stick
to it don't puss because it's like you
got to think about like what you're
doing in the moment actually doesn't
matter the effects are going to come 10
20 years later compounding you know so
like I forgot you got to compound the
pound yeah so I forgot what it was it's
like me and Gio were like telling taica
something if this happens again like I
forgot like you can't you're not going
to get ice ice cream tonight or
something whatever and then um you saw
blow on not getting ice cream tonight
you punished yourself because you wanted
ice cream I'm just give you an example I
forgot what it was and then he he's like
okay cool he he you see the remorse he's
changing and then the rest of the night
he like [__] crushes it does
everything he's supposed to do homework
jitu whatever right and then so like me
and J like we just go take I'm to get
the ice cream and then Grandma was like
No And I'm like oh thank God one of us
was [__] has like a kind of sticky to
the standard cuz you can see where like
someone still has Integrity yeah yeah
and that way they know like you can't
[__] up and then be good temporarily and
then now like the world is going to bend
washes away yeah and he obviously he
doesn't know he's just but if we like as
the parents we're creating the tracks
you know so like he's just the car
that's moving down and if we make a
really soft track at the end when he
becomes 15 he's like [__] I'm [__]
entitled because you guys so just like
kind of keeping that in mind like
everything we're doing now is like like
stick to it like if we said something if
as much as it hurts us emotionally you
got to stick to it so that he knows the
rules are like this you know you're
doing them the consequences are real my
biggest thing is like your kids aren't
like I you're not your kids aren't my
kids so your kids not like the gift to
that God gave everybody and [__] yeah so
like when he's jumping on my [__]
bed I don't think it's the cutest thing
I've ever seen want your kid to not jump
on my [__] bed especially if it's
someone else's bed yeah that's what I'm
saying that's what he's saying yeah
you're talking about like kids going to
your house and jumping on your [__] yeah
jumping on my [__] and it's like why are
you [__] jumping on my [__] and I'm
like oh I don't find it cute like the
parents like this is czy so cute look at
them they're all so cute and I'm like no
they need to not jump on my [__] bed
cuz they're I don't even think they're
cute at all now like I wish that the
story books were real and then an old
witch would eat them in a
St keep jumping on my bed dude with your
shoes on yeah you little [__] but these
people just think their kids are just
the [__] [__] dude I I wanted to um
choke the [__] out of this little
[__] team cuz first off he was in
first class and I just don't believe
that that should be happening you got
send the back my boy Kids In First Class
yeah well like he was probably like 16
or something right he should be where
you store the luggage exactly with the
chick under the plane so he's with his
parents right we're on the same row and
then um this [__] waits till
we're taking off to go to the bathroom
the the this [__] plane is lifting
off he had so much time he takes off his
thing the the uh flight attendant he's
like where do you think you're going and
he's all like well I have to go to the
bathroom he goes oh sit back down the
the the the thing's on and he goes we're
not ready you can't go up and then so he
gets back down he pouts and he's like
complaining to his dad and [__] and then
he goes I need to go and his dad's just
like oh just hold it and then he's like
I have to I have to go and he's like
pouting and [__] right and his dad's
just like well don't let him see you
yeah and I'm all like I would [__] your
whole family up right now and then the
flight attendant had to deal with like
an emergency so in the mid takeout off
thing he gets up he leaves and then he
[__] looks around the corner and he
bolts through and goes into the bathroom
takes a piss comes back out and I was
just hope he spilled everywhere dude I
was like dude this is how they
teach why these [__] kids grow up all
in titled we had a parent like that at
Jiu-Jitsu so Jiu-Jitsu they try to teach
it as a team right tell about if if they
[__] up everyone's doing push-ups like
they don't even care like if there's
like this whole group's talking all five
are doing push-ups right so there's one
time where all these kids are like doing
push-ups and the dad goes up to his kid
you don't have to do the push-ups you
did nothing wrong and I'm like your kid
is going to get beat so bad when he's
[__] in high school cuz he's going to
be the not me I'm not on the team yeah
I'm like what the [__] dude I'm glad
he's not there anymore but I was like
that makes me want to [__] up the dad is
that a surprise that he didn't stick
around that's that's not a surprise
right no it's not but I was like [__]
[__] dude doesn't that make you want to
grab his dad's ear and pull it and go
now you got to do pushup good dad of
course he doesn't no people do this [__]
that their kids like the anointed one
and [__] my kid's the [__] second
coming of Christ he's special yeah it
it's just like dude you know like you
got to you got to realize that not
everyone cares and not everyone thinks
and by the way oh my kid's like you know
it's really crazy cuz like he's already
learning the ABCs and like he's just way
ahead and it's like your kid um I know
how to do algebra
yeah if your kid can do algebra and he's
seven years old then we then yeah then
you could be like Oh I'm not blowing the
[__] away that your kid knows how to say
[__]
hats all right when I was coaching
Jiu-Jitsu class for kids CU we give the
kids like Stripes as like a way of like
okay progression it's a sign of like hey
you know these amount of techniques
you've been showing up consistently
you've been working hard so it's like
okay this is like a reward thing it's
earned it's not something we just give
out just because you're there or
whatever right but there's one parent
she would bring his kid and the mom was
so annoying dude just like she was a
pain in the ass but and she would bring
her kid
like once a month maybe right and then
all the other kids got promoted and then
she's like how come my son didn't get
promoted this kid doesn't really listen
that well he doesn't really pay
attention so it should be clear why yeah
yeah and he doesn't show up consistently
so it's like how is he going to
understand the moves if he doesn't show
up consistently this is not something
you just do once a week and then says
all right that's it so she like
complains about like well he you know
he's been working really hard and he's
been doing such a good job he should get
these Stripes blah blah blah blah blah
but it's like think about what you're
teaching your kid to be that entitlement
because I think my kid is so special but
in reality it's like didn't put the work
in well it's not even yeah it's that too
but it's also like Jiu-Jitsu is not
about getting Stripes bro it's about
being able to defend yourself and be
competent in these skill sets so you can
be able to like KCK ass exactly and if
you don't have that why are we going to
give this kid a stripe it's only doing
him a disservice yeah take him to
techwondo yeah exactly and on top of
that he sees his friends getting stripes
and he's not getting Stripes don't you
think that'll help him like be like oh
you know what maybe I'll start working a
little bit harder maybe I'll do a little
bit more but the mom is like I'm [__]
writing email I'm complaining and I'm
going to threaten this business and
write like bad reviews and you're like
oh so you're the [__] problem you
know like this lady dude but it just
happens she should she should take her
kid away someone should take her kid
away this is like I I started seeing
more about this I don't know if this
would be like major offensive to
everybody but like is it uh I was
reading something about how like
damaging it is for young boys to be
around too much feminine energy I think
that could be potentially true I think
kids I think you need a balance no
everything they need cuz you know we we
most in most of History we were in like
a very diverse age Society like with
grandparents and other kids our age but
now we're very like Factory assembly
line where we're in our group's
generation up until we like die cuz I
was reading something that show every
age you know it showed a statistic
showing that like 70 something per of
the teachers they will have as they grow
older are going to be women so that's
already a large chunk of their time and
what they're learning and then if their
dad's not around as much then that's
almost 100% influenced by like women as
a product of a lot of a female household
I think I could have used yeah look what
happens to me dude how soft I am yeah I
have no hair on my legs it takes me
forever to grow a mustache and he has
toxic masculinity he's always fighting
all the time shaving his leg to get his
tattoo we couldn't tell which one he
shaved yeah and I you know I could have
used a lot more masculine energy growing
up I think no like I think about that a
lot actually I think I think I could
have too honestly yeah for sure that's
why we get along so well all right turn
it off dude it's
whatever I would like to share one thing
and I only got this because uh you know
nah is a doc of occupational therapy and
I would say in terms of unsolicited
parental advice uh
that
it a little Laurel and Hardy bit that's
all well he was talking about Junie for
like half an
hour I think it applies I would say that
I had to plug in my
business parents probably should not
have too much pride or fear of like
maybe having their kids uh take
advantage of like government funded
developmentally delayed programs early
because there's a lot of times where
kids will have developmental delays and
they might just be like oh let me just
give them more time or they might be
concerned but not want to say anything
you know what I mean and it's like these
there's a lot of programs that the
government is already paying for it you
know what I'm saying so it's like take
your kid in and get an assessment and
see if like they could get speech
therapy they can get like you know some
more resources exactly it's already
there but there's a lot of times that
people have pride and they don't want to
do something and then it's a little bit
late and if you would have just brought
your kid 6 months in early or something
like that it could be a huge difference
dude if my kids aren't even then I'm
going to start doing that [__] you
should yeah it's like I insist no he
needs help free service [__] put him
in there Hooked on Phonics baby it's
already there you know so I like what
Joe was saying about jimby a lot more he
say it
again this kids don't on a
mop